winner winner chicken dinner all night
to say that oh my gosh it just smell I
mean hey that's not grandma's house good
look at you getting all culinary with me
oh dang that is really good you know I'm
at home
you posted a mini it shows for Food
Network right there's been a variety
that Rachael vs. guy can drink versus
guys loves that grocery games those kids
in are we in today where are we so you
are in the world famous Food Network
kitchens I'm smelling so many delicious
things over here but I'm definitely
smelling some chicken so I want to know
this is the scoop on this boss sauce
that we got here some chicken chicken
guy so you know beating that you have
some Southern roots I wouldn't make
chicken that had a lot of flavor
I wanted the bread to be sure to be not
all breading and a little bit of chicken
I wanted me a lot of chicken a little
bit of reading and I wondered me flavor
on top of flavor on top of flavor on top
of flavor and we developed this and we
would do every single element of what
you see to make what we call some of the
best friends you can get right on all
right big deal it is a huge deal because
being from Nashville which is like hot
chicken I did get me the princes any
time right I'm gonna make you a chicken
sandwich we only have 22 handmade sauces
so I hope if we put them all together
the combinations rebel I love it all
right so let's talk about the chicken
now the first thing is it's got to be
fresh never frozen chicken okay natural
chicken this is a chicken tender this
isn't the breast
this is that side muscle so super tender
and this has been brined in buttermilk
garlic pickle juice a couple other
things just I'm gonna - so now we're in
the year all right so go ahead and glove
up okay we roll my sleeves up cuz I'm a
professional
okay not really right I'm gonna take it
it sounded good I got it I got it all
right okay so first thing with the
chicken tenders so we've got all-purpose
flour with a little bit of corn starch
okay so we're just gonna add in a little
seasoning a little oregano okay you can
help you jump in paprika
okay go pack for you guys okay how much
do I go it's that happen a little
granulated garlic now what I want you to
think about a little onion before your
hands get wet give a little stir look at
that so we took the chicken - chicken
brined for about 24 hours okay
oh yeah pepper so Brian for about 24
hours we Pat it dry and then what we're
gonna do is get into this dredging cycle
so first things first grab a piece of
the chicken okay
now this is where things can get really
breaking up it - in there you go - in
you live on the edge
okay now you get the other hand and this
is the dry hand method okay oh yeah kiss
your Winnetka got it wet hand dry hand
yeah otherwise it just starts to clump
now the question is how many of those
can you do before you forget which one
was the one in and was dry an yeah this
is exactly how you do it so this is okay
so give it a little shake good perfect
you've almost shake like that and into
the wet liquid and that's just a little
bit of just chicken no no I'm still cuz
I was dry on my right arm I like I'm
just trying to right oh yeah I don't
start to competition right now okay all
right there you go
now with the wet hand yep did you just
use your dry hand it wasn't dry what I
gotta stick it back here cuz I'm gonna
forget now we're gonna go into the
breadcrumbs little panko little bread
little cornstarch little rice flour okay
okay a little bit of seasoning in there
now with the dry hand we're gonna cover
that back up now this is where it gets
really key once we get this covered up
now you got to give it a push okay you
have too much in there if you have too
much of the breading in there it
adhere to the chicken now we pull that
out flattening that bad boy out exactly
give it a little press that watch in
there there you go
so what's happening is by pushing it
down a little bit you're really making
that bread crumb adhere to it and you're
flattening it out a little bit which
gets us the right thickness throughout
okay okay hey and then we left this ooh
that's a good right now cumin but she
that's what I want you to look at is the
breading it's not just a ton of reading
now we're gonna use the airfryer I think
this is a great way to do it especially
when you're cooking at home right give
these a little spray a little cookie
spray on top air fryers running well how
long do you throw them in the air fryer
ten minutes well it depends on how many
you have in there and did it heat up
ahead of time gotcha okay the air fryer
goes down close it up let it rock oh my
gosh it just smelled I mean hey that's
not grandma's house don't even taste it
yet a little bit of a spice blend here
some salt some pepper some paprika some
granulated garlic some granulated onion
okay we sprinkle that on in the key is
to sprinkle that run right when it comes
out so it's nice and hot and that the
seasoning will just kind of melt right
into it okay
look at you getting all culinary with me
brioche bun
now that nice I mean almost like I want
people that don't know what a brioche
photos I want you to think about a nice
almost like a doughnut but without the
sweet right so we toasted on both sides
both sides of the bun look at that how
go now the question becomes here is the
question the question is where's the top
the question is what kind of sauce do
you want to put on have you come back
here to the cornucopia of sauces cuz
they only have 22 you know what we had
35 when we argued about it and then we
said that we had to bring it down they
thought I was gonna go to five I said
okay 22 now one of my favorites is
donkey sauce if your head
so now it just sounds awful it's the
best name ever and look at him is
through a donkey sauce is mayonnaise is
boring
it's egg annoy and that's all but I said
you could take this and you could make
this really flavorful what we would call
an aioli so making it ourselves a little
bit of garlic a little bit of mustard a
little Worcestershire a little black
pepper he's got a little bit more flavor
to it then that's what donkey sauce this
is donkey sauce do I have a spoon big up
you're gonna have to go to finger okay I
washed my hands y'all don't get grossed
out every finger yeah okay so that now
the reason that I call them that is some
good donkey the reason I call it this is
because I have some buddies and we were
getting ready to build this burger
concept and they said well what is this
sauce that we're gonna put on there and
I had just made the sauce up and I said
I don't know but if you don't put it on
there you're a you got the point and
that was the joke that was it okay well
we didn't know that they were gonna take
that and go literally with it and call
it that so he goes up on the menu know
by now that anything you say is fair
game I didn't know that one was fair
game so we put a little bit as a donkey
sauce on okay right that is now now
we're gonna start getting really into
this the question is where do you want
to go after it now we got sweet and sour
we got Ranchero salsa chipotle ranch
I'll show you one of my favorites is
right down here where's the Perry Perry
the Perry Perry but for you I know I
have to Nashville hot honey okay
we'll bring this right over here okay so
now we're gonna build it first thing
we're gonna do is right on the bottom of
it i layer them out so in case someone
doesn't even want pickles on them too
bad that's sad sorry there and the
flavor is already into the bun yeah okay
it's already worked his way into the bun
that's the beginning now a little bit of
white onion now grab a couple pieces of
chicken okay
oh wow you will yeah okay
couple piece of chicken on there righty
now you want to go cheese do you want to
go with the bacon do you want to go some
potato chips all right where do you
think we should go a good crunch oh I
just love these chips so much groan I've
never met a kid or a french fry no I'm
exactly that up there you go now we're
at the restaurant I would go ahead and
melt that but we're gonna kind of
proceed on okay next step yeah couple
tomatoes yeah oh my gosh they're just
shy so well there we go tomatoes on top
of this now do you want to go the
question is we have a little bit of the
lettuce just a little we're gonna get
some bacon in there to help me there you
guys a little bit Meagan are you ready I
bet you got a moose listen this is hard
to show you this this is there's this
the final step of this creation
now what are we gonna show on yeah now
there's no turning back now okay
go ahead you can do it hit us with it I
feel like I need a bid you're gonna
practice okay there you go hit it up be
generous be generous boy oh my go
yeah now we're getting into this this is
where we're gonna separate the beginning
cooks from the real deal - chips cheese
bacon donkey sauce Nashville hot honey
toasted brioche bun both sides pickles
lettuce onion tomato give it to give it
that come on there you go we had a
little more you got a little power in it
yeah you've got so now I want you to
look at this and prepare yourself and
you got to get a little bit of the hunch
you're gonna wear some of this yeah okay
hey it's my hair back yeah I think we're
good she's running back to me yeah there
we go at eight one two three
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on okay good wife thank you oh oh
dang that is really good
so what happens Wow nothing go did you
look at all those layers inside of that
sandwich do I have any right here oh
yeah you got a little I do they can't
hear you guys do you what a team we are
yep I'm good you know what I think this
is good yes winner winner chicken dinner
oh I just say that you know that just so
you know that was sandwich one we got 21
more to do okay so get ready don't get
your hopes up we'll see you in a bit